I have to ask you about this there was a
very famous controversy it with the Red
Sox the last season three pitchers
admitted that they were having beers in
the clubhouse during games and I was
just curious you know this world you
know this life is that something that
happens is that fairly happens yeah it
happens but it I'm generally if I had a
beer in the clubhouse it was after I had
pitched and I was in that Clubhouse
icing my arm or I wasn't gonna play have
a beer every now and then sure right how
many beers like well I mean I didn't
generally start chugging or anything
like that and I certainly didn't order
chicken it's just it's just around it's
it's something you grab a beer every now
and then again after I pitched out of a
game so you knew you weren't going out
and you thought that I wasn't like you
know swinging a bat get ready to
pinch-hit slamming a beer swinging I
mean I was you know I was out of play
okay okay you were known as a great
prankster and I was curious in the
clubhouse what was one of your favorite
pranks well my favorite one was freezing
people's clothes yeah so you would you
would it was fun on the road you would
find somebody's street clothes which
they would change from their uniform
they come to the ballpark and when they
went on the field you'd stick him in the
freezer in the locker room before the
game started so and it was generally
always best on getaway day when you were
like flying home because you could put a
suit and tie and everything in there
yeah and then after the game when they'd
get showered uniform off their clothes
would be frozen on the hanger and and
I'm a would they would come to
hypothermia enjoyed that no no no well
they didn't never knew that was part of
the game was was being able to do it not
be caught oh they never knew it was you
know so you had to get yourself once oh
yeah
and for some reason I'd have a spare set
of street clothes
all right we had pitching ace Justin
Verlander on the show recently and he's
famous for giving the hot foot we
actually have and I know that since
you're a connoisseur you're an expert on
pranks I want to show you Justin
Verlander's hot foot and you then you
assess it for us would you mind look at
that clip right now Kelly's foot is on
fire oh my goodness he still doesn't
know that's terrible you by the way done
your foots on fire all right assess it
give us that's give us your color
commentary it's a potentially perfect
execution
yeah because he's clearly far away from
the scene of the crime when the victim
realizes that something's been
perpetrated on I mean he's been set on
fire but in the friendly way in the
bilious world oh yeah the friendliest
way one completely yeah justin is a
cheater I've seen him he uses alcohol
rubbing alcohol to to incentivize the
flame to be much bigger much faster he
rubs the shooter with alcohol before why
don't you pour rubbing alcohol because
the Hokie you crawl under the bench you
missed the whole setup part of this yeah
you crawl under the bench generally
where guys are sitting and you like the
shoe on fire when they're sitting like
that and then you crawl out and go away
and either they burn and let's see
younger players it's one of those back
in my day stories younger players don't
appreciate it for the true Nate pure
nature of it they use alcohol so if
you're really good in old school you can
do with just a match yeah you know and
and so but it's still that was a so what
you're saying is Verlander is juicing
[Laughter]